ah did you little kitties miss Santa
Oh Santa back because it's that time of
year that I've got to go around to the
other houses and deliver presents to all
the ungrateful little bastard kitties
all around the world
cuz I'm contractually obligated to not
because I want to anyway let's use just
all my last senior Dickinson and missus
[ __ ] a lot ah whatever and they got
like 13 bajillion kids cast look and all
that how well let's see what's going on
here and why wasn't he Direction lovely
that had to build all the toys this year
by himself because for some mysterious
reason there's entire workshop a little
kid he seemed to one can easily explode
they other know what happened but ah
don't matter
hey yeah we check my naughty list
haha Wow looks like Santa's been a good
boy this year I got a lot brother I look
better over there Oh lock one for me all
from stannic to stannous lovely oh my
favorite
another one without a Claud Oh lovely
indeed oh wow God my job here is done
Hey oh well Stan I'll promise the big
man downstairs that he wouldn't get into
the sauce I don't think he was looking
be the blow man it was made of cocaine
it wasn't no don't you know I'm higher
than a plane
just Anna's list here oh those things
are well yeah you have electricity huh
well you don't need those cuz death
don't have a lock busy up in the North
Pole there doesn't even have a gosh-darn
boiling down are you gonna the goodies
wife is you
deck the halls with boughs of blood the
philosopher before [ __ ] you and the
season 2 gives down all of your toys you
damn bastard titties or don't care where
you will go now
put it up go Thank You al maybe someday
you'll know what I go through every day
however you do it better shut of it dad
took five everyone
well okay thanks I'm good man Oh 12 our
girls resistor game goose Tara
well gold bars 11 balls rules right well
I enjoyed a second okay you still there
and yes we escaped and 9 bagger hi
well no what happened flags all of us
drank a bit too much hey bottles of wine
7 bastard cootie stick something else
reindeer
well four giant bazooms free friends
something's two more bazooms and our new
flavors mana
oh boy Faust I'll just use a key to the
ding dog damn office lost Danica going
it's very fricking way I get all this
stupid are you looking please please hey
that is bad person that's good what I'm
sorry friend doesn't have anyone to rely
on that is it no I don't think Stella's
doing very well fires lonesome mrs.
Claus left me the other day that all
can't even begin to think about things
Astaire did but yeah Jax I like bad
things got real bad up in the doors Bowl
then I had to eat all the rage here to
fuel the fires of my rage was yummy
matter because it was just a little bit
I'm gonna drink all these balls there's
nobody gonna kill you bastard
kitty they're all bankers bombed order
on the bum bum then I want you all to
die your dumb dumb dumb
mm boom
gals AR ùl I love you all joy
Giselle just put a fetus purse or Stan a
happy to see Santa Anas dreaming of the
play boy model one who wants to stand in
Santa's lap oh she can algae die balloon
boys are the face full of pretty and
ends down we'll stop her stalking Oh
Santa's gonna split it with bill y'all
deserve this ooh doggies are these fries
those deserves that ball but I can't do
anything about that one your Jersey left
you don't deserve this warranted you
know Geoffrey it's our best bouncy fun
back your time thanks Terra can see that
his hairs annoy well you heard it off
now okay Joe
yes I move that we must be there that I
would like to take a moment to say
how'd your life was going to be here for
you little kitties night after night
after night after night after night
after from afar improving night display
always Aerostars Burgas enjoy your job
baby
not really bullet dance contractually
obligated to stay loaded last